if you want to land a big customer start
small find one thing that you could go
in make it super low risk for them over
deliver like crazy and you'll end up
blending the big fish if you go in just
trying to sell the big picture changes
are you not going to make it hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneur's deserve help and today
making a question from a customer Diego
who wrote in to say that he bought my
worksheets and they're great Thank You
Diego he provides services to general
contractors and builders I'd like to
know how to approach a client that has a
good relationship with a company I've
known for many years and how can I get
their business how can I win business
against someone who's already doing well
for them so here's the thing Diego if a
company already has an existing supplier
it's hard for you to go in and knock
them out completely okay if they're
doing a lot of business with a company
it's been years that they've done it
it's hard for you to go in and say hey
get rid of them and use me here's your
opportunity you have to find a hole
you've got to find one small thing that
the client is either unhappy with or the
supplier isn't delivering properly one
small project and you may even lose
money on it at the start because of your
time invested into making that
relationship happen but you want one
small tiny insignificant project because
it's easy for them to say yes to that if
you can find something that their
supplier is not doing or not doing well
and just get that little piece that's
your way in its your thin wedge in it's
easy for the company to say yes to that
once you get that project you over
deliver like crazy you provide so much
value you go way above what they
expected you provide amazing service
they have a problem you're there to help
solve it more business is going to come
to you you don't even have to sell it
they're going to compare you to all
their other suppliers and you have to be
the best you have to be the most
responsive you have to have the best
quality so when they have any other
problem coming up they're going to say I
wonder if Diego can do that
and if you can you jump on it and you're
going to get more business and more
business and more business and it was so
easy to getting because you're just
starting small it's super low risk for
them when i first started work with some
of my corporate clients they came and
asked me to do some blog posts for them
they wanted 500 words three to five
hundred words and for me to write on a
regular basis so fine we'll start that
off their hiring me and 10 other people
to do it I didn't just write three to
five hundred words I wrote two thousand
words and i made a video and I promote
it to my audience for the whole week and
I drove tons of traffic and I was highly
engaged on their site I gave them way
more than they asked for and as a result
I was able to increase my prices by five
times and get way more business from
them I turned what started off as a
five-hundred-dollar project into over
fifty thousand dollars a year because I
over delivered like crazy and I started
on a tiny little nothing project and
they hired me over the 10 other bloggers
because those guys were just doing what
they were asked and some of them are
doing a great job of only what they are
asked they didn't go beyond you have to
think what else you can do to provide
awesome value to your customer so that
any time an opportunity comes up they're
going to come to you first and say I
wonder if Evan can do that I wonder if
Diego can do that and I keep getting
calls from my past customers and my
current customers to say hey we have a
new project do you want in they come to
me first because I over deliver when all
the projects that I've done for them and
you need to do the same I love selling
the big business because it's repeat its
ongoing it's big dollars and it's a lot
it's the same amount of work to line a
big deal as it is to learn the small
ones and instead of you chasing your
tail the other these small deals all the
time you go after a bigger company you
become important to what they do and
you're going to be in there for as long
as you want making big dollars so it's a
great strategy to go after start small
start on a tiny project over deliver
like crazy and they're going to throw
tons of business your way good luck I
want to hear about your success for
those of you watching you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and I
want to hear from you too if you have a
question about this video or
comment for your own company please
leave in the comment section below I
really read those every day I love see
them come in thank you so much and I'll
see you soon